[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
el desplazamiento causado por los
desastres climáticos es una de las
consecuencias del aumento de las
temperaturas miles de personas alrededor
del mundo deben movilizarse dentro y
fuera de sus fronteras para huir de las
tragedias naturales y este fenómeno
estaría lejos de detenerse según
estimaciones del banco mundial el cambio
climático podría causar la migración de
unas 216 millones de personas para 2050
de américa latina' aportaría 17 millones
a ese número en 2020 dos fuertes
huracanes impactaron centroamérica y
obligaron a muchos a emigrar veamos
algunos testimonios en el siguiente
informe
los campos de la comunidad cerro azul en
guatemala ya no son los mismos el que
antes era un terreno verde ahora es
suelo estéril los huracanes eta ello
está diezmaron los cultivos de cardamomo
y dejaron a cientos de indígenas sin su
siembra pero familias de este pueblo
maya perdieron más que sus terrenos
lázaro tuvo que despedirse de su hijo de
17 años que decidió emprender un viaje
hacia eeuu
bueno no quiera mandarlo pero como él
decidió irse fue él
no digo que nos quedamos nos quedamos
sin nada parece hoy
como buscar el hijo de lázaro se estima
que más de un millón de centroamericanos
fueron desplazados por el impacto de los
huracanes en 2020 tal vez en la
actualidad digamos la violencia la
pobreza en general sean las causas más
importantes sobre todo en honduras el
salvador y guatemala
pero en ciertas comunidades se sabe
verdad que ese fue el detonante ya
tenían la pobreza ya tenían otras
condiciones y viene un evento climático
y eso es lo que da el último empujón
digamos para que la gente decida migrar
el refugio santarrosa acoge a unas 2.000
familias desplazadas de pueblos que
fueron devastados por las inundaciones
leopoldo y su esposa marilyn viven aquí
hace 5 años los efectos del niño un
fenómeno climático que se estaría
agravando por el calentamiento global
los dejo en la calle no y cuando venimos
acá es como empezar de la nada porque
tenemos que comprar nuestras cosas de
nuevo la cama la tenemos que comprar los
roperos tenemos que comprar los
servicios porque todo todo todo se lleva
el agua los desplazados dependen de
pozos para abastecerse en una región que
alcanza temperaturas diurnas de hasta 35
grados celsius desde la organización
internacional para las migraciones
llaman a los gobiernos a dar respuestas
podríamos pensar que el 10 por ciento de
la población del perú estaría siendo
afectada de manera directa o indirecta
por el cambio climático recuerde que los
agricultores al no tener fuentes de agua
pues obviamente tendrán que buscar
alternativas para poder subsistir
entonces
el trabajo del estado del trabajo de los
gobiernos es ver cómo estos movimientos
estos flujos poblacionales se pueden
controlar las consecuencias del aumento
en las temperaturas no sólo afectan a
américa latina en bangladesh cientos se
desplazan por la crecida de las aguas
esto en un país considerado muy
vulnerable ante el impacto del cambio
climático
ante ese infortunado panorama de
desplazamiento por contextos de
desastres y cambio climático un grupo de
refugiados en camerún decidió tomar
acciones y plantar miles de árboles para
reforestar la zona desértica donde viven
se trata de un gran muro verde que se
extenderá a lo ancho del continente
africano este su aporte
este era el campo de refugiados de mina
guau en camerún hace tres años y así se
ve ahora
paso de un paisaje desértico a un
espacio con más de 360 mil árboles que
fueron plantados por la comunidad que
vive aquí
la gran muralla verde busca extenderse a
lo largo de ocho mil kilómetros por el
sahel
y así combatir la desertificación en uno
de los lugares más secos del planeta
min agua se ha convertido en un lugar
que es verde por todas partes esto tiene
muchos beneficios
tenemos sombra del sol el suelo ha
mejorado y los árboles se atraen el agua
organizaciones de ayuda decidieron
invertir en el planeta y así mejorar las
oportunidades de vida en este pero en
torno
sólo hemos centrado nuestras acciones en
la reforestación y la sensibilización
también estamos superando retos como la
tala de madera hemos establecido una
estrategia con acnur para promover
fuentes de energía alternativas como el
uso de briquetas ecológicas
ashour leal enrique technology
la llegada de refugiados a camerún
aceleró la desertificación ante la
necesidad de los nuevos llegados por
obtener leña
ahora unas 100 mujeres trabajan para
producir y vender carbón que es usado en
estufas adaptadas para minimizar el
impacto ambiental en el campo de mina
guau viven más de 70 mil refugiados en
su mayoría nigerianos que escaparon de
boko haram
según la organización meteorológica
mundial hay un 40 por ciento de
probabilidades de que las temperaturas
aumenten durante los próximos cinco años
lo que desencadenaría más desastres
climáticos y seguramente el aumento de
los desplazamientos a causa del clima
hasta que inmigrantes de france24
los invitamos a comentar en nuestras
redes sociales con el hashtag migrantes
f24 sigan con más información en france
24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]